foreign
last week I posted a very important poll
to Twitter the question who is the worst
wife in America there were four options
Jill Biden Meghan Markle Jada Pinkett
Smith and Gisele fetterman the wife of
Senator John Federman now it proved to
be a close contest the one clear winner
emerged at the end Jada Pinkett Smith GI
Jane as Chris Rock would call her who
has uh escorted her husband Will Smith
through one public humiliation ritual
after another won the race with 32
percent of the vote close behind her was
Meghan Markle assuming her preferred
position by riding someone else's
coattails with 30 and then first lady
and notorious Elder abuser Jill Biden
with 22 followed finally by Gisele
Federman with only 14 percent of the
vote
but after the events of this past week I
must now call for Mike Pence to do the
right thing and throw out these results
we need a new election and I think
Gisele Federman deserves to win this
time
now Gisele earned the title before this
past week she earned it ever since her
husband nearly died from a stroke during
a political campaign and she rather than
insisting that he leave the race and
save his health in the process instead
help to shuffle him along from one
campaign stop to the next where he
humiliated himself with increasing
regularity only to eventually win the
senate seat because the Republicans
managed to run someone who was less
appealing to voters than an actual
vegetable somehow fetterman would um
end up in the hospital almost
immediately after being sworn in and
then again immediately after that he was
admitted over a week ago for his second
stint and is still there reportedly to
receive treatment for depression now I
must say reportedly because there's no
reason to believe any of the details
were given about fetterman's health at
this point all we can say for sure is
that the man is not well
that didn't stop Giselle his loving wife
from going on vacation anyway the daily
wire here's the report Senator John
fetterman's wife was slammed on social
media Friday after she revealed that her
first the first thing she did after her
husband was hospitalized with severe
depression was flee the country to go on
vacation fetterman checked himself into
a hospital last week for a multi-week
inpatient treatment regiment after the
attending physician United States
Congress recommended that he do so
Giselle fetterman who lived illegally in
the U.S for more than a decade said that
she took the family to Canada for a
vacation after leaving her husband in
the hospital NBC news reporter Dasha
Burns said last week that senior aides
the federmen have indicated that it's
been difficult to distinguish the stroke
from from the depression saying it's
hard to tell at times if fetterman is
not hearing you or he is he is sort of
crippled by his depression and Social
Anxiety
quota senior aide tells me both the
staff and fetterman himself were taken
by surprise by the severe onset of
depression the aid also says that this
hasn't compromised his ability to do the
job going forward and he'll be back to
work once he was once he's taken care of
his mental health
um so wait
just side note you can't tell if he
hears you when you speak to him
but that hasn't compromised his ability
to do the job of a senator
which actually might be true but what
does that tell you about the job of a
senator
as for the details of Gisele's impromptu
Excursion out of the country while her
husband languished in the hospital she
tweeted this quote
I'm not really sure how to navigate this
journey but I'm figuring it out slowly
one week ago today when the news dropped
the kids were off from school and the
media truck circled our home I did the
first thing I could think of pack them
up and in the car and drive we drove
straight into Canada we talked Lots
about hard things and how we all have to
face hard things about the need to be
gentle with ourselves and with all
we did some scary things but we did them
together we ziplined over Niagara Falls
and August got stuck we talked about
flexibility and the need to always have
an open heart and an open mind we also
talked about how joy and fun can and
must still exist even when someone we
love is in pain and tomorrow who knows
we'll try to do it all over again
now she also uh provides some pictures
and videos from their jaunt to Niagara
Falls
it should go without saying that
a good and attentive wife does not leave
the country on vacation while her
husband is experiencing a catastrophic
medical emergency
now we don't know whether John fetterman
is even fully conscious right now but if
he is I can only imagine what it must
have felt like when he called his wife
from his hospital bed expecting that she
would sound distraught only to hear
laughter and commotion in the background
like what's that honey oh we're uh we're
going ziplining in Canada it's so fun
wish you could be here anyway gotta go
of course it's it's not that a man in
the hospital wants his wife to be
miserable but he does want her empathy
he wants her concern her support
all of which seems to be lacking in
giselle's Behavior
of course some people have tried to
defend Gisele by insisting that while
she was only trying to get away from the
media Spotlight it was something that
she did to protect her kids they claim
that doesn't make any sense given that
Gisele has ruthlessly pursued the media
Spotlight and she was willing to
sacrifice her husband's Health to get it
you can't push your barely cognizant
husband over the finish line and into
the Senate and then five seconds later
claim that you wish to Shield your
family from public scrutiny
that would have been easily achieved if
fetterman dropped out of the race after
he had his first stroke during the
primers remember that first stroke was
during the primaries
he could have easily just dropped out
and another Democrat would have been uh
would have been would have been the
nominee
and probably would have won the Senate
but now that he's a senator
you know now that you've made that
decision to push him over the Finish
Line his health is a matter of national
interest and importance
that's what she wanted and now she has
it
but even if we could justify the Niagara
Falls Tour on the basis that she was
trying to avoid the news cameras take
her kids Minds off of everything in the
process that wouldn't explain why she
needed to publish a string of tweets
about the experience complete with
pictures and video
Giselle seems to have gone to the Meghan
Markle School of protecting one's
privacy and even more to the point it
would not explain or Justify what she
says in the tweets and what she doesn't
say you'll notice that her husband's
name isn't mentioned she never expresses
any concern about him
and said she talks about herself her
journey her need for joy and fun
she has turned her husband's medical
crisis into a personal journey of
self-discovery
and in that way and in several other
ways she is you know the quintessential
modern liberal woman and I don't mean
that as a compliment
it's actually appropriate that on the
same day that Gisele published her tweet
Thread about her fun vacation another
tweet written by a different but equally
vapid liberal woman went viral this time
it was um
Dr Nicole lepera is a psychologist and
an expert in quote unquote self-healing
lepera has amassed an enormous online
following with gems like the one she
posted on Friday which says this quote
putting everyone else's needs before
your own isn't selfless it's
self-abandonment Society glorifies this
and it's a massive reason why so many of
us are unwell
yes that's the problem with society that
it encourages people to be selfless
the solution to our cultural problem
therefore says the psychologist is to
put greater emphasis on selfishness
because that's the ingredient we're
missing obviously surely we've all
noticed this I mean when you when you
look around at Society the first thing
you think is well there really isn't
enough selfishness out there
this is totally backwards of course it
may be theoretically possible to go too
far in putting other people's needs in
front of your own
theoretically that's possible Maybe
but that is not the direction that our
culture pushes people
and if you're having trouble in your
relationships it is almost certainly not
because you are too outwardly focused
too worried about helping others too
selfless
that may be the story that you tell
yourself
but the story is almost always fiction
and it is a fiction grounded in your
selfishness
Giselle fetterman is a prime example of
this phenomenon
and a very public example
because that's what she wanted to be
and that is why she is today finally
canceled that'll do it for this portion
of shows move over to the members block
if you're not a member yet you can
become a member and use code wall should
check out for two months free on all
annual plans
hope to see you over there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]